max scherzer they acquired him from the
nationals for games just like this
i mentioned earlier that 12 starts he's
made for the dodgers the dodgers have
not lost the game those are his numbers
in those starts but got taken out in the
fifth inning of the wild card game in
his last three starts two regular season
in the wild card era is close to seven
this will be his 20th career postseason
start won a world series with the
nationals two years ago and max scherzer
just lost his balance probably the win
kind of blew him
offline
see him going to his his mouth there
again on a dry night these are northeast
winds these are very unusual wins
for this part of the country three and
two on yashrimsky now the stella at
first and that one's in there called
strike three
caught him guessing
and scherzer dials it in picks up his
first strikeout of the night two men
aboard la stella and posey and that'll
bring up brandon crawford now here's
another 3-2 and crawford a swing and a
miss
jurors are pounding that inside corner
can't get a better pitch on a 3-2 count
perfect on the corner elevated so it's
impossible for crawford to get to it
bryant his career just two for 20
against scherzer here he comes and a
swing and a miss he struck him out
scherzer strikes out three left-hander
alex wood
wood who
earned a world series ring last year as
a dodger lookie betts
one for four in the first game of this
division series and then he had two hits
and an rbi in game two
wood fires
and did he go they'll ask he did
a ring up at first base by pat holberg
and it's a strikeout to start the game
for alex wood now longoria in his career
two for 19
against scherzer scherzer fires
and a swing of the miss
elevated the fastball and longoria is
strikeout victim number four well one
thing that is different from the wild
card start with max scherzer is that he
has swing and miss stuff tonight his
fourth strikeout just a totally
different start
to this game than it was in the wild
card now here's steven duggar two and
two to duggar
and he got him oh he
shook it went to the changeout
[Applause]
five k's for max scherzer
three up three down second inning he's
retired five in a row pollock is a great
fastball hitter who get a lot of slow
stuff from wood tonight
had a big moment in game two drove in a
pair with a double this time it's a
strikeout and that will in the inning
and six in a row for alex wood second
time around now tommy stella owen to the
count
got him
charged with a strikeout it's the second
strikeout tonight or the changeup he
struck out duggar for the final out of
the second on a change one of the
loudest ovations of the night for that
man the great albert pujols he's in the
starting lineup tonight
it is his first start in a postseason
game since 2014.
you know i think
i don't know if we knew he needed it but
having a veteran guy like that's been
awesome and he might have hit a double
right there a little flare good call
that's going to get down double's a
little aggressive
that's fair
and now pull holes at third base and
mookie vets in a long battle here with
alex wood
popped him up
keep an eye on it
la stella
he's got it and the inning is over
buster posey will lead off for san
francisco
and a wave of the miss scherzer had him
out in front
that big nasty slider by max scherzer
and strikeout number seven
and scherzer is on a run now nine in a
row retired see how he gets on the side
of that seam and spins it and wasn't
only the location of that slider it was
the change of speed on that slider that
had posey out front here's lamont way
junior wade meyer in a long slump right
now he's just two for his last 32 at the
plate here he comes
and he got him strikeout number eight
for scherzer who's now cruising with gas
the dodgers with two on first time
they've had multiple runners on base
tonight against alex wood and that's
gonna bring up aj [ __ ] here he comes
on the ground one hopper crawford goes
the easy way to second and alex wood
gets out of the mess nothing nothing as
scherzer goes back to work here in
inning number five emma longoria coming
up two strike pitch there's a swing of
the high drive in the left center field
way back there still going on its way
down
and evan longoria picks dodgers stadium
game three of the division series
to find himself
a soaring booming home run over the 375
marker and well up into the bleachers
out there
one nothing giants grimsby has struck
out and flied to right one or two the
count
ski hits it hard to center field on the
run is taylor and he makes the catch
chris taylor
ran right to the spot on this windy
night
beautiful play
by the speedy tailor man that ball just
took off a liner to center field
taylor was sprinting back
and finally caught up to it
just before he got to the wall on the
warning track and then his momentum
carried him right into the padding and
the tying run is aboard here in inning
number six for chris taylor and taylor
into center field that ball is hit hard
on the run
and making the catch duggar oh what a
play the center fielders putting on a
show in this game duggar and taylor matt
scherzer
back on the mound for la here's a
one-two
and scherzer with a strikeout
that cutter down and in two up two down
max scherzer with strikeout number 10.
longoria came into the game
hitless in his previous 23 at batson
with two hits in his last 40.
and then he hit a home run 2-2 pitch in
the air center field on a line taylor is
over he's got it another terrific catch
one win
outfielders making plays
all game long aj pollock gets it started
rogers deals bouncing ball
over his solano gloves it to his feet
and he makes the play
oh what a play
donovan solano
silky smooth going into that slide in
the 360 spin he was skidding across the
shallow outfield grass and in one motion
with great footwork spun around popped
up
and fired a perfect strike to first two
on two outs lucky bets at the plate and
that is a liner caught by crawford
brandon crawford goes up the ladder
takes a hit away from mookie betts
inning is over wow what a play brandon
crawford
i didn't think he could get up and get
it
the giants defense tonight has been
amazing
two men are out and now the dodgers
down to their last out and it's gavin
lux the 1-0 locks in the air that balls
hit well that ball's back duggar on the
track makes the catch to end the game
and the giants
win game three one to nothing
michelob ultra organic seltzer as real
as it tastes